panont d'être extrêmement vigilant à
nous de les accompagner au maximum
bonjour stéphane beaudet maire d'evry
grunge et d'autre evry courcouronnes
chez moi je suis tout seul j'ai à la
fois cette chance et puis en même temps
parfois on sent un petit peu seul et je
réponds à votre interview c'est l'un de
mes rendez vous de la journée journée
qui en télétravail complètement
désorganisée commence à 6 ans le matin
effet leader 23 24 heures le soir
alors étant mère je suis évidemment en
activité je suis très majoritairement en
télétravail même si parfois je sors
notamment pour la distribution de
masques d'avoir conçu par messi sur les
commerces et j'ai continué à fonctionner
comme d'habitude c'est à dire des
produits frais bio locaux évidemment
quand quand c'est possible
et puis une fois par semaine je vais
faire mes courses dans une grande
surface
oui dans un premier temps entre les
premiers jours du confinement j'ai
acheté beaucoup de choses sur internet
beaucoup plus que je ne le fais
d'habitude mais j'ai réglé assez vite
cette consommation / sur internet
alors justement essayer d'abord de
privilégier nos produits locaux je sais
qu'ils sont parfois un petit peu plus
cher enfin la qualité s'en fait
ressentir c'est bon pour l'emploi local
c'est bon évidemment pour la planète et
puis c'est bon pour nos artisans locaux
aient pu donner un conseil c'est
évidemment même si on est tous un tout
petit peu fashion victim du e-commerce
d'y aller un tout petit peu mieux vaut
quand même je me suis battue autant
président de l'association des maires
d'ile-de-france pour que les marchés
forains puisse se tenir là où on en
avait besoin
et donc c
comment les services d'artisans
producteurs locaux qui peuvent venir
encore vendre ou accompagné on la met en
place sur notre ville par des paniers
celles et ceux qui sont isolés qui ne
peuvent pas se déplacer qui ont aussi
besoin de consommer des produits frais
de qualité
pas forcément je pense que ça doit nous
interroger collectivement parce que
parfois il n'y a pas de prise de
conscience collective mais c'est dans
certaines campagnes municipales où les
enjeux c'était la révolution
environnementale et sociale et la
révolution digitale numérique d'une
certaine manière cette crise sanitaire
nous pousse à hiré j'espère qu'il en
sortira indemne j'espère que les mises
en place la fois des régionales
le local le fait que l'on puisse leur
ouvrir l'accès par exemple le au marché
pour pour les producteurs en aidera
certains mais ça ne recouvre pas toutes
les professions de l'artisanat et gp en
malheureusement qu'il y en ait qui soit
qu'ils soient sur le carreau à nous
d'être extrêmement vigilant à nous de
les accompagner au maximum je suis pas
leur place est très difficile il faut un
petit peu d'humilité je suis le donneur
d'ordres je suis maître d'ouvragé en
tant que maire d'une grande commune je
suis consommateur à mon échelle à moi
dans les marchés à moi dans ma vie
quotidienne d'essayer de l'est de les
faire vivre
à eux de se positionner à eux d'être
visible est accompagné par la chambre
des métiers et de l'artisanat de pouvoir
développer les réseaux qu'il faut sur le
territoire pour être présent je suis
face afin que me concernant elle le fera
je pense qu'elle le fera pour pas mal
d'habitants mais j'avais déjà des
pratiques très bio depuis très très
longtemps aux circuits courts depuis un
peu moins longtemps que en tant que mère
évidemment en reprenant les chantiers le
plus vite possible en étant le plus
actif possible mais on va être confronté
comme les artisans à la pénurie sans
doute
crédit bancaire voilà donc c'est un
système économique complet qu'il va
falloir qu'on remettre qu'on remette
ensemble
en tout cas moi je la suis en tant que
maire nous voulons seront aux commandes
depuis que possible je suis extrêmement
favorable on y travaille dans nos
marchés de l'appel d'offres pour les
restaurants scolaires où on était déjà
en bio à 60% repas 100 bio local à plus
de 50% voire à 100 % dans les prochaines
années donc c'est aussi une façon de
soutenir nos producteurs locaux dont le
fait également avec le département avec
la commerciaux et avec la région donc si
on s'y met tous pensent que nos
producteurs locaux s'en sortir on
traînait bas à reprendre une vie tout à
fait normale travail et bien sûr ou mais
reprendre mon vélo pour faire plus de
sport à l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur
et puis c'est de profiter des beaux
jours
[Musique]